looking at the time and looking at where
you're up to I'm going to solve it one
way and then I'm going to show you the
answer and introduce increased attention
and then see if tonight for homework you
go you can work out what's going on good
teachers and I'm not saying I always
delete ugliness actually I'm trying I'm
trying work could teach us introduce
tension because it's boring if it's like
there's a set of steps you do it is the
answer don't question why what I prefer
is that you're like wait but huh yeah
that kind of thing right that helps you
learn it helps the stuff stay on the
ground
okay now cipher x- science huic when you
look at that except for you what's the
first thing that jobs have and your mind
for how to work with it
Oh bingo thank you okay actually
ironically that is the fuse yeah okay
so and there is a there's a clue to
point you in that direction daily that
there's a 2x and a forint
okay so it's sort of leading you in that
direction so so for actually expanded
out using double angle and here's what
you get so far so good
okay so when you go ahead with this you
can factorize it take out that sine 2x
and you get this okay so now I'm landed
in the situation that I had before
namely I've got two things to solve okay
so I'm going to solve this sine 2x is
equal to zero that looks familiar and
then I'm gonna solve this tracking with
it that's why we're practicing yet all
right so let's quickly do this one
because we in fact did it like just now
okay
general solution for sine is recite with
me okay
and my plus minus 1 to the 0 okay that
was a bad idea all right
and since I introduced the end I'm gonna
say what it is oh okay all right so that
zero is going to disappear I'm going to
go straight to this line okay
so that's nice that's good everything's
working fine so far
over here the chin X is equal to now the
general solution for cosine is two
different letter pi right plus or minus
now what's my angle in this case okay
now again like ever this side I should
introduce okay
they don't divide through by two divide
everything through by 2 by the way that
includes this relate Nagle sitting on
the apple pie lands it okay yeah that
looks pretty good to me okay I'm quite
content with that
but it's not what they say the answer is
they say the answer is this one we're
about ready might look at the homepage
okay instead of this pair of general
solutions by the way there's no nicely
way to put these together okay so you
just have to say or okay they also have
it or in their answer but the two things
on either side they or ask for two
things we've got they've got x equals n
pi or x equals two pi on 3 or 2 2/3
right plus or minus pi on 6 now I know
the first time I saw this and before
I've actually worked out what's going on
I thought clearly I've got to be right
or the techsoup's copyright but mutually
exclusive the thing that threw me off
with a lift update anyway Oh what do be
obvious is on
cuz I'm like okay this no.13 here what's
going on okay
now you can't sure enough generate a
table of values and these will be
exactly line up which is interesting my
question to you I want to know that you
think you're out over the next four
minutes and tonight is if indeed these
two answers are legit right um how did
they get this one we got this and it'll
give you a clue the way to work out I
think the the hint to work out how to
actually do this is actually all about
that three that three is crucial okay
the thing that I think the problem I got
with three they've got a three huh that
three is actually the key to working you
know how they do it and I think it may
even be a more elegant way of solving it
than this I'll let you decide tomorrow
no spoilers if you think you got it put
it put it down okay but I'll come around
and have a look and say whew you're on
the right track
but if not what you want to kind of
think about it cuz spoilers ruin movies
and they ruin maths questions too